Hitler was a Vegetarian
Now he wasn’t always a vegetarian.
In fact, it was later in his life that he
became one.
Around the same time he was killing millions
of Jews and millions more from other cultural
backgrounds and trying to take over the world.
Coincidence?
I think not!
According to transcripts translated by Hugh
Trevor-Roper, apparently on November 11, 1941
Hitler said, “One may regret living at a
period when it’s impossible to form an idea
of the shape the world of the future will
assume.
But there’s one thing I can predict to eaters
of meat: the world of the future will be vegetarian.”
In further conversations on January 12, 1942,
he said, “The only thing of which I shall
be incapable is to share the sheiks’ mutton
with them.
I’m a vegetarian, and they must spare me
from their meat.”
He also liked to bombard dinner guests with
graphic descriptions of slaughter houses he
had visited in the Ukraine as a way to turn
them off meat.
In addition to this, while watching movies,
any scene in a movie that had the killing,
slaughtering, or otherwise abuse of an animal
in it, he would look away and have someone
tell him when it was over as he couldn’t
bare to watch.
In fact, he couldn’t bare it so much, that
the Nazi party banned such scenes in film.
If this isn’t enough irony for you, consider
the amazing number of animal rights laws the
Nazi’s created and enforced.
The Nazi’s banned commercial animal trapping
and vastly restricted hunting among other
things like restricting the shoeing of horses
and banning boiling of lobsters.
One fisherman was even sent to a concentration
camp for cutting up a frog for use as bait.
After passing many of these animal rights
laws, Hermann Goring, a prominent Nazi party
member, said those who “still think they
can continue to treat animals as inanimate
property” will be sent to concentration
camps…